[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier bei Bild mit
einem Mann der ohne Zweifel ja
klartext-politiker ist ein Mann der in
der Politik polarisiert wie kein anderer
einer der nicht geliebt wird schon gar
nicht mehr von den Grünen der aber
gewählt wird zumindest in Tübingen
zuletzt mit großer Mehrheit dort Boris
Palmer bei uns bei Bild herzlich
Willkommen an sie mit ihnen möchte ich
heute sprechen ja über klimakleber hier
in Berlin heute wieder über Wärmepumpen
über Schulklassen in den mittlerweile
niemand mehr deutsch spricht auch bei
Ihnen um die Ecke und auch darüber über
diesen Satz der gestern Abend in einer
sehr prominenten Talkshow gefallen ist
da ging es um den Satz vom
sachsenministerpräsident Michael
Kretschmer der sagt Deutschland alleine
könnte doch nicht das Weltklima retten
halten Sie diesen Satz für problematisch
naja also da Objektiv zutreffend ist ist
ja erstmal für mich trivial und deswegen
nicht problematisch die Frage ist was
soll daraus folgen soll daraus folgen
dass wir nichts tun müssen dann fände
ich in problematisch ich hoffe aber dass
er das nicht gemeint hat es ging in der
Diskussion die ganze Zeit darum warum
jetzt Heinz 75 Jahre alt verstehen muss
dass ganz schnell nämlich schon 20 24 er
sich dann perspektivisch um eine neue
Heizung kümmern muss wenn doch sowieso
das in Sachen Weltklima kaum etwas
ausmacht darum ging es halten sie Bezug
darauf diesen Satz wie eine will gestern
sagte in der Sendung für
hochproblematisch
nein gesagt ich halte nicht für
problematisch weil seine Realität
beschreibt ich würde ohnehin davon
abraten einzelne Sätze zum Maßstab der
Beurteilung von gesamten politischen
Konzepten oder Personen zu machen so
fragen was will er denn jetzt tun also
die Frage die ich hätte wäre Herr
Kretschmer was machen wir denn jetzt
also wenigstens heizungsgesetz nicht
sein soll was ist die Alternative und
darüber würde ich keine streiten aber
nicht über diesen Satz und streiten wir
konkret über das aktuelle heizgesetz
Millionen Deutsche haben natürlich Angst
vor allen Dingen die die ein Haus oder
ein Häuschen haben die haben Angst die
ihren Wohlstand zu verlieren aktuell
auch wegen dieses Gesetzes geht die
Heizwände im Moment nur mit so einem
Ruck oder wie Entspannung Moment in
jeder Ecke sagt in jeder Sendung sagt
mit der Brechstange
also erstmal hat die Heizwände so wie
sie vorgeschlagen wird was logisches für
sich wenn 2045 in Deutschland keine
CO2-Emissionen mehr zulässig sein sollen
daher übersehen sich ja sogar alle
Parteien einig im Bundestag dann ist es
nicht sehr sinnvoll 2025 noch eine
Heizung einzubauen die um wirtschaftlich
zu sein eigentlich länger laufen muss
als 2045 so das ist meine logische
Ansage und jetzt kommt halt die
Übersetzung in die Praxis und da wird es
dann schwierig wenn ich nicht weiß wo
kriege ich den Berater her und meine
überhaupt funktioniert nicht denn nicht
ab es gibt in einigen steht nur ganz
wenige ja Energieberater schon mal tot
oder für die ausgebucht also wirklich
den Berater her wenn ich nicht weiß
welche Technik ich nehmen soll wenn die
Technik dann bei mir vor Ort nicht
verfügbar ist und wenn ich kein
Handwerker findet auch nicht 60.000
vielen aktuell in Deutschland Fachkräfte
bei weitem nicht und wenn der Handwerker
der sagt ich würde da kommen aber ich
kriege das heißt du möchtest nicht
geliefert also da finde ich sitze das
Problem und deswegen Wolken kuckucksheim
ein Stück weit nee es ist eine Frage des
Übergangs also wie manage ich diesen
Übergang und ich kann Ihnen sagen dass
wir in Tübingen da versucht haben
einfach früher anzufangen dann fällt es
leichter das heißt unsere Stadtwerke
bauen ja verja die Fernwärme aus und für
mich ist es auch der Königsweg so wie
Skandinavien das gemacht hat eigentlich
sollte man den Leuten diese vielen
vielen Entscheidungen wie komme ich denn
jetzt zu Wärme in meinem Haus abnehmen
und sagen hier ist das Gesamtpaket wir
schicken Dir die Wärme direkt im Keller
und sonst musst du nichts machen sie
wollen den Tübingen schon 20 28 glaube
ich nur noch mit erneuerbaren Energien
auskommen richtig 20 30
aber wir machen das dann nicht mit einer
Maßnahme ab morgen ist irgendwas nicht
mehr erlaubt sollen wir versuchen
systematisch die Voraussetzungen zu
schaffen das ist von selber nicht mehr
gebraucht wird das haben wir halt Jahre
lang verschlafen und jetzt wird den
Menschen aber zugemutet dass eben ganz
schnell zu machen was halten Sie von ihm
von dieser Brechstangen oder hoch
Politik
ich würde den skandinavischen Weg besser
finden das heißt diejenigen die die
Wärme liefern verpflichtende so zu
machen das ist im Klima nicht mehr
schadet und dann möglichst schnell
gucken dass die Umrüstung auch
funktioniert also Druck auf die Konzerne
heißt das auf die Energie auch auf
Stadtwerke Netzbetreiber es sind nicht
unbedingt immer Konzerne aber
Netzbetreiber ist halt ein Unternehmen
dann nicht mehr Einzelperson also ich
würde den Druck stärker auf das Angebot
richten da könnte sehr viel mehr laufen
da sind wir weit im Rückstand und nicht
ab 01.01 den einzelnen Hausbesitzer zum
verantwortlichen machen der plötzlich
völlig hilflos ich glaube das
eigentliche Problem ist das Gefühl der
Ohnmacht ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ich
tun sollten und das müssen wir
überwinden wird hier Vertrauen verspielt
ich glaube es wird Widerstand produziert
es ist erzeugt großen Widerstand ich
merke es dass viele Menschen die
eigentlich auch dem Anliegen des
Klimaschutzes aufgeschlossen sind an der
Stelle sagen ich weiß gar nicht was ich
machen soll was ich tun soll und ich
verstehe es nicht und das erzeugt sich
ja Widerstand den wir eigentlich nicht
gebrauchen können wie wird da gesprochen
sie haben das jetzt sehr diplomatisch
wiedergegeben deckt sich das tatsächlich
mit dem was sie hören auf der Straße in
Tübingen wie geschrieben gesprochen wird
über die Bundesregierung über das
heizgesetz über den Wirtschaftsminister
über den Wirtschaftsminister nicht aber
über dieses heizgesetz wird gesprochen
und überwiegend ist da Sorge und
Unverständnis zu spüren für uns
allerdings tatsächlich auch eine Chance
weil wir jetzt überrannt werden von
Anfragen vor fünf Jahren habe ich noch
gesagt wir brauchen den Pflicht dass
Leute die Fernwärme mit der Stadt nehmen
die umweltfreundliche Ferne habe ich
auch durchgesetzt in einzelnen
Stadtteilen und da gab es viel Ärger was
das sollen und obwohl und zu teuer und
heute ist es so dass ich aus allen
Teilen der Stadt Briefe kriegt man
endlich kommt die Fernwärme zu mir ins
Haus also von daher hilft es tatsächlich
auch wenn man dann verbaut hat also die
tolle so pittoreske romantische Altstadt
in Tübingen die können sie komplett mit
Fernwärme beheizen das werden wir machen
das ist unser Plan nicht nur die
Altstadt sondern wirklich die gesamte
Kernstadt wir haben schon gut
ausgebautes Netz und wir werden jetzt
die Investitionen vervielfachen und vor
allem werden wir die Erzeugung umstellen
auf erneuerbare in alles toll gedämmt
die alten Häuschen muss man gar nicht
also die alten Häuser alle toll dem das
ist für mich jetzt gar nicht vorrangig
das dauert auch viel länger als 20 30
sondern die Heizung austauschen das geht
viel schneller und einfacher wenn man
nur eine Warmwasserleitung reinlegen
muss und der Schlüssel ist dann
erneuerbare Erzeugung wir brauchen jetzt
eine große solarthermische Anlage die
erzeugt also Wärme und speist die direkt
in die Rohre und wir bauen eine Anlage
zur Rückgewinnung der Wärme aus dem
Abwasser am Auslauf erkläranlage in den
Neckar ist gut für den Neckar der nicht
überhitzt und die Wärme dort ist
praktisch erneuerbare Energie die wir
rückspeisen in die Rohre dafür werden
die Leitung und damit können wir
tausende von Heizungen von einem Tag auf
den anderen auf erneuerbare umstellen
das ist für mich der König sogar noch
fahrradbrücken beheizen in Tübingen
Deutschland im Moment über das
heizgesetz streitet und überall in den
Köpfen ist menschlich krieg ich meine
Heizung irgendwie klimafreundlich wie
setzt sich dieses Gesetz und beheizen
sie in Tübingen sogar die die
fahrradbrücken das stimmt allerdings mit
Strom nicht mit Fernwärme und das bleibt
aber das bleibt auch denn das ist für
das Klima besser als die Brücke zu
salzen Sie sehen die da wunderbar eine
von den
fahrradunternehmen vier Wochen im
Betrieb die sind beheizt weil diese
Stahlkonstruktion wenn man sich schnell
hier sehr stolz da war ich wie stolz
wenn man diese starke Konstruktion
ständig mit Salz überfrachtet dann
korrodieren die schneller und Stahl ist
sehr energieintensiv das heißt das
bisschen Heizstrom ist gut investiert
auch fürs klimaan außerdem sollten
Radfahrer auf seiner Brücke halt nicht
stürzen also dieser Mann der
Oberbürgermeister von Tübingen sagt bei
ihm geht die halswände irgendwie
leichter von der Hand es kommt früher er
hat früher dran gedacht deswegen fällt
es jetzt leichter er schafft sogar die
Altstadt er baut sogar noch
fahrradheizung bei sich Fahrrad
brückenheizung ein jetzt passiert im
Moment folgendes wo die Bundesregierung
uns sagt na Öl und Gasheizung das sind
die Auslaufmodelle gehen diejenigen die
jetzt eine Heizung brauchen los und
kaufen Gasheizung zu 70%, wie passt das
zusammen das ist immer so also wenn es
so eine Last Minute Option gibt dann
wird die von den Leuten auch genutzt das
wird man nicht verhindern das scheint ja
gar nicht besonders überzeugend zu sein
dass man uns sagt Gasheizung sind ein
Auslaufmodell persönlich ist es dann ja
auch nicht so wenn ich sie habe kann ich
sehr behalten denken immer an die
Glühbirnen da gab es auch ein Run wo
Leute Glühbirnen gekauft haben bevor die
dann ganz verboten werden trotzdem haben
wir heute alle LED das Studio hat keine
Glühbirne mehr würden sie das selber so
tun würden Sie sich jetzt eine
Gasheizung anschauen würde ich nicht ich
glaube das macht macht wirtschaftlichen
Fehler weil die fossilen Energie so
teuer werden dass man über die
gesellschaftlich oder moralisch
wirtschaftlich dass man über die gesamte
Lebensdauer dieses Gerät draufzahlt aber
das sehe ich heute noch nicht und
deswegen sagen die Leute kurzfristig ich
will dieses Problem gelöst haben nämlich
noch die Gasheizung das haarbäckchen
oder das Ampel heizgesetz ist das sozial
in ihren Augen das hängt ja stark davon
ab wie diese Zuschüsse ausgestaltet
werden die sind einkommensabhängig in
Teilen von daher nicht so richtig ne in
Teilen also nicht alles
einkommensabhängig aber es gibt einen
Bonus den man nicht kriegen kann wenn
man so viel verdient wie Sie und ich von
daher ist es in Teilen
einkommensabhängig das Dumme ist nur
dass das halt eigentlich vom Haus
abhängt also das zu beurteilen geht gar
nicht hier am Tisch denn dazu müsste man
das Haus kennen und das und das
Einkommen das Besitzers aber hätte das
nicht dazu gehört dass man das zuerst
den Menschen sagt dass man ihn erstmal
die Angst nimmt dass er es erstmal sagt
okay wir haben hier oder schaffen uns
einen großen Topf dort werden diejenigen
die es nötig haben entsprechende
entlastet das wird abgefedert ihr müsst
euch erstmal keine Sorgen machen dass
unsere eure Häuser massiv an Wert
verlieren werden dass sie möglicherweise
sogar auf eure Altersvorsorge verzichten
werden müssen weil die entweder das
ganze Geld aufbringen müsste eben für
die Heizung oder weil sie sogar euer
Haus
verkaufen müssen
das war ja wohl die Absicht ist dann
aber vereitelt worden in dem ein Entwurf
des Textes ohne diese Teile an die
Öffentlichkeit gelangen was in der
Politik ja fast nie passiert was in der
Politik durchaus passiert aber es war
zumindest keine Absicht ist so zu machen
das Ergebnis ist aber wie sie sagen wenn
der Teil noch gar nicht im Text drin
steht dann ist natürlich die
Verunsicherung groß aber ich glaube das
hat habe ich am meisten geärgert der hat
ja nicht absichtlich rausgegeben es muss
jemand anders gewesen sein sind wir
Schuld nein ich bin finde überhaupt
Suche nach Schuldigen völlig und
produktiv das bringt keinen Menschen
weiter er lassen Sie mal die Schuldfrage
einfach weg es gibt Ursachen es gibt
Konsequenzen und die zu analysieren geht
auch ohne Schuldfrage Folge ist das die
Menschen heute immer noch nicht ganz
genau wissen die Hauseigentümer was
kommt da eigentlich jetzt genau auf uns
zu vor allen Dingen eben finanziell auch
weil die FDP ja jetzt noch mal ankündigt
das ganze Ding zu kippen wenige Tage
nachdem sie dem zumindest die
Parteispitze zugestimmt hat ist das
jetzt total schlaue Partei Taktik oder
verlogen
keine Ahnung ich glaube nicht dass es
verlogen ist weil ich der FDP schon
abnehme dass sie das was sie da sagt
auch will es ist aber zumindest für
einen fernbeobachter da sehe ich mich
als fernen Tübingen ist ziemlich weit
von Berlin so ungefähr 600 Kilometer ist
es irgendwie schwer verständlich was das
zu bedeuten hat wenn da Vizekanzler oder
ist er Vizekanzler offiziell nicht aber
so ungefähr ja also der Koalitionäre
fdp-parteiche fdp-parteiischer wenn der
dazu stimmt da im Kabinett und am
nächsten Tag sagt der Parteitag wir
wollen aber ganz anders jetzt warte mal
ab was das Gesetz dann wirklich sagt
also im Moment ist die Unsicherheit was
in diesem Gesetz drin stehen wird nicht
beseitigt ich kann es eben nicht sagen
wie gehen sie mit der 80 PLUS Regel um
also 80-Jährige sollen jetzt davon
ausgegangen sein weil möglicherweise
eben die Lebenserwartung geringer ist da
sozusagen ja er heilt die Zeit dann alle
heizungswunden im Heizungskeller das
scheint der Gedanke dieses Gesetzes zu
sein finden Sie das sinnvoll und vor
allen Dingen verfassungsfest
verfassungsfest kann ich Ihnen nicht
sagen ich bin kein Jurist ich habe mich
sehr gewundert als ich gelesen habe und
ich kann mir nur einen Raum drauf machen
dass die von ihnen vorher gestellt ist
halt sehr alle Fragen der Grund ist dass
man also den Menschen ab 80 nicht mehr
zumuten will über eine Investition zu
schreiben die mir 79 gegen mutet man es
halt zu ne die wesentlich länger laufen
wird als ihre Lebenserwartung in aller
Regel das ist wohl der Gedanke dabei ob
das jetzt eine gute Lösung ist ich
verstehe welches Problem gelöst werden
soll aber ich wundere mich auch ein
bisschen über die gefundene Lösung sie
gehen ein bisschen zumindest in diesem
Gespräch recht schon mit Herrn Harbeck
um haben reichlich Kritik immer an ihrer
Partei ja auch an ihrer noch Partei muss
man sagen offiziell sind sie noch
Mitglied die Mitgliedschaft gut
irgendwie irgendwas dazwischen sind sie
derzeit der Robert Habeck zieht
wahnsinnig viel Interesse auf sich
einiges der einzige Minister den die
Masse in Deutschland aktuell kennt der
polarisiert im Moment noch stärker meist
als sie ja Palmer sind sie da ein
bisschen neidisch ist der habe der beste
Palma im Moment nein ich sehe das
tatsächlich eher im Moment nur über die
Medien übers Fernsehen persönlich habe
ich ihn nicht getroffen eher mit Sorge
weil er für mich tatsächlich jemand ist
der es ernst meint mit der Energiewende
aber auch mit
demokratischen Instrumenten dahin zu
kommen und im Moment gerade da wird man
ihm glaube ich nicht unrecht tun kann
man nicht sagen dass ein guten Lauf hat
gerade extrem und diese ganze wärmewende
Diskussion geht nicht so in die Richtung
wie er sie sich vermutlich gewünscht hat
wie ich sie mir auch für ihn wünschen
würde deswegen das analysieren sie
richtig versuche ich gerade sauber zu
analysieren ohne da Vorwürfe zu machen
weil jetzt nachträglich alles besser zu
wissen ist auch wohl falsch ich hätte
vor zwei Monaten nicht vorhersagen
können dass diese Wärme wenden
Diskussion so aus dem Glasgeräte ich
finde sie ist völlig aus dem Gleis
geraten und jetzt denke ich halt darüber
nach was könnte man noch tun meine
hauptantwort ist
viel stärker auf die Netze setzen weil
man dann die Verantwortung von den
einzelnen die sie nicht tragen können
wegnehmen zu können die meisten
ärgert einfach dass ein riesiges Problem
eben auf den Schultern ja sehr einfacher
oder der Menschen ja abgelegt wird die
sehr wenig haben und nur ein kleines
Häuschen eben haben das war Wort
Wärmepumpe spielt eine so große Rolle
sind sie wärmepumpen-fan nein ich finde
es auch sehr schwierig Fäden einer so
simplen Technologie zu werden dann kann
ich sagen wer Wärmepumpen Fällen
beispielsweise ist Staat im Hause von
Harbeck das Wärmepumpen mit dem was er
sagt und so wie wir werden wahrnehmen
also Fan bin ich vielleicht von dem
Fußballverein aber nicht von der
Heizungs-
spielt leider nicht in der Bundesliga
also ich bin dann in dem Fall bin ich
nur Fan von den Tübinger Basketballern
weil die sind gerade super und könnten
vielleicht in die erste aufsteigen
kleine Ausflug wir gehen zurück zur
Aufstellung von Robert habex
ministeriumte gerade Patrick reichen und
es gibt gerade heftige Diskussionen dort
über den Leitungs über den Führungsstab
von Robert Habeck verschwägerte
staatssekretäres ein Stichwort aber auch
die Verbindung zu bestimmten grünen
Think Tanks die immer wieder auftauchen
finden Sie dass das Ministerium so
rechtmäßig und auch richtig moralisch
richtig aufgestellt ist also bei den
beiden Fragen um zweifelhaft ja das
heißt nicht dass es sachlich immer alles
richtig ist wer kann das schon für sich
beanspruchen aber dass da irgendwas
unmoralisches oder nicht rechtmäßig sein
ganz sicher nicht richtig nach
klüngelwirtschaft nee das ist meiner
Meinung nach Zusammenarbeit
denken Sie mal dran zurück dass es
Zeiten gab in denen die
Versicherungen Entwurfe für Gesetze von
FDP gesundheitskatastrophe geschrieben
haben das ist eine Form der
Zusammenarbeit die nicht in Ordnung geht
wenn man erkennen kann dass die Gesetze
gar nicht mehr aus dem Parlament also
Ministerium kommen sondern von den
Betroffenen Lobbyisten da würde ich
sagen ist die Grenze aber dass man sich
fachliche Expertise reinholt und die
dann auch in Gesetzestexte einfließen
lässt ist was anderes wenn es keine
Verbindung mehr gibt zur politischen
wissenschaftlichen Debatte zu einem
Gesetz wäre ja auch ganz schlimm und mir
scheint ist der legitime Teil der
Zusammenarbeit zu sein von dem sie
sprechen noch verschwiegung der
Staatssekretären schon ungewöhnlich ich
sage den Teil weiß ich gar nicht wer hat
da wen geheiratet es geht unter unter
anderem um Michael Kellner es geht um
die Familie von Patrick reichen gucken
uns gerne noch mal anders Organe kam
okay also bis gerade eben ist mir das
nicht bekannt gewesen sie interessiert
mich nur ganz wenig wir bleiben noch
einmal bei den Wärmepumpen weil die eben
auch mit dem Staatssekretär reichen so
eng verbunden sind wird jetzt aus einem
gasheizungs- und ölheizungs Deutschland
ein Wärmepumpen Deutschland ist das
tatsächlich unser Heizungs Deutschland
also technologisch wird es wohl in
vielen Fällen so sein dass die
Wärmepumpe die einzige verfügbare
Alternative ist zu fossiler Energie und
das will ich schon einmal sagen den
Ausstieg aus den fossilen Energien halte
ich für absolut richtig ob das jetzt
Deutschland als erstes macht oder wie
auch immer die Welt muss raus von diesen
fossilen Drogen sind wir abhängig und es
geht nicht ganz ohne Schmerzen das wird
so sein aus vielen Drogen sagen sie das
ist eine Droge ja weil sie macht das
Leben erstmal schöner und am Ende sind
aber nachher doch alle irgendwie dabei
ziemlich krank so als globale
Gemeinschaft betrachtet wenn dann die
Feuerstürme und das Arten sterben über
den Planeten hinwegfegen dann hat es
schöne Leben übrigens Konsequenzen das
ist so wieder Kokain Rausch irgendwann
machte halt auf und dann sagt der Körper
jetzt nicht mehr ich glaube dass das
billige Energie aus Versehen Quellen mit
einer Droge ganz gut beschreibbar ist
also langfrist ein bisschen halt die
Schäden erst zu besichtigen deswegen ist
der Ausstieg daraus richtig und heute
ist sicherlich da wo keine Netze
verfügbar sind die Wärmepumpe die beste
verfügbare Technologie gebaut werden die
Dinger jetzt in Osteuropa Bosch baut da
Viessmann bauter in Polen unter anderem
super Entwicklung für Deutschland super
gelaufen na ehrlich gesagt solange in
der EU produziert wird ist es nicht das
schlechteste wenn wir wenigstens ist
noch schaffen Wertschöpfung in der EU zu
halten kann ich daran nicht schlechtes
finden die verlängerte Werkbank zu
billigeren
Produktionsstandorten hat viele
Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland die letzten
Jahrzehnte gesichert das scheint mir
nicht schlimm problematischer finde ich
da könnte man eher darüber streiten wenn
wir z.B auf die Chemieindustrie gucken
die wegen Energiepreisen und Regulierung
möglicherweise den Standort Deutschland
einfach gar nicht mehr halten kann und
dann in Asien produziert und weil der
nächsten großen Krise merken wir dann es
kommt nichts mehr rüber ja hatten wir ja
gerade erst da würde ich eher drauf
gucken aber Arbeitsteilung in der EU ist
für mich okay
sie blicken als Baden-Württemberger dann
natürlich auch ganz stark auf die
Automobilindustrie wie wird sich da das
Land in den nächsten Jahren verändern
mit Blick auf die Kernindustrie in ihrem
Land also da müssen wir vielleicht auch
die Frage noch ein bisschen erweitern
ich bin ehrlich gesagt im großer Sorge
um die Wirtschaft unseres Landes weil da
viele Faktoren gleichzeitig
zusammenkommen die einen Stress erzeugen
bei dem ich nicht sicher bin ob der
überstanden werden kann also wir haben
den Abschied vom Verbrenner der kommt
uns zweifelhaft wir haben
Arbeitskräftemangel es gibt Betriebe in
Tübingen die mir sagen ich habe keinen
einzigen Auszubildenden mehr Wachstum
wenn findet nur noch im Ausland statt
vielleicht in Polen weil ja keine Ahnung
weil sie damit angefangen haben das ist
ein chinesisches Wort in Zukunft
in chinesische Wort ist auch der
elektrisch betrieben eine Kleinwagen den
baut kein einziges deutsches Unternehmen
möglicherweise ist das die eigentliche
Gefahr wir haben Fachkräftemangel die
Migration ist nicht am Arbeitsmarkt
ausgerichtet es kommen überwiegend
Menschen die lange in sozialen
Unterstützungssystem leben werden und
wenig beitragen zur Wertschöpfung und
die Fachkräfte gehen lieber in andere
Länder weil es bei uns nicht attraktiv
ist wir haben die völlig verkorkste
bürokratische Überregulierung die jedes
Jahr schlimmer wird und alle möglichen
schutzanliegen isoliert betrachtet so
aufeinanderturm bis kein Mensch mehr
damit klarkommt und sagt am besten nicht
bewegen sonst was falsch wir haben die
energiekostenkrise wenn sie das alles
aufeinandertürmen und dann fragen
passiert da genug um den Standort
Deutschland zu sichern dann sage ich Ja
oder habe ich große Bedenken wir
vertiefen gleich einzelne Punkte sie
haben jetzt ganz viele gemeinsam rein
gemischt die ja ein eher düsteres Bild
mal von ihrem Bundesland dann denken wir
uns nur in Anführungsstrichen einmal die
Autoindustrie noch mal weg aus
Baden-Württemberg wie sieht ihr Ländle
danach aus
na das sieht deutlich ärmer aus ja oder
Industrie ist eine Quelle des Wohlstands
und Sicherheit viele Arbeitsplätze in
Baden-Württemberg
düsteres Bild wenn die Autoindustrie ist
nicht schafft die große Transformation
dann sieht es wahrscheinlich eher nach
Ruhrgebiet aus in den 30er Jahren heute
ärgern sich viele Autofahrer hier in
Deutschland mal wieder über hier in
Berlin in der Hauptstadt mal wieder über
die klimakleber und es entsteht nach so
vielen Monaten der Eindruck dass in
manchen Städten gibt es ja Kooperationen
auch sie haben gesprochen ein Deal
gemacht sozusagen
im Moment nicht behindert wird aber darf
der Staat dürfen darf die Polizei das so
lange mit sich machen lassen immer und
immer und immer wieder also erstens
dienstags nicht geben ich habe über die
Frage ob in Tübingen blockiert wird
nicht gesprochen gar nicht auch nicht
verhandelt habe den im ersten Satz
gesagt darüber rede mit mir nicht die
rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien gelten
trotzdem rede ich gerne mit euch aber
nicht darüber sondern über Klimaschutz
und was man tun kann haben wir auch
gemacht und dabei bleibt das ist in
Tübingen noch nie eine Blockade gegeben
hat liegt glaube ich eher daran dass es
bisher keine Gruppe in Tübingen gibt die
das gerne machen würde vielleicht auch
weil unsere Klimaschutzpolitik zeigt
dass es in Tübingen sowieso ernst
genommen wird und wenn uns dann fast
überall tut sie ist in Hannover gab es
tatsächlich so eine Art
mir nicht es äh funktioniert dann
ausnahmsweise nur bei Ihnen vor der
Haustür ansonsten wird überall blockiert
heute massiv in der Hauptstadt und immer
und immer wieder man kriegt das nicht in
Kraft der Staat kriegt das nicht in
Griff hier sitzen immer wieder da kann
man sich so lange darf man sich so lange
auf der Nase rumtanzen lassen
die Frage ist was man tun kann ich finde
das ist notwendig ist dass die Polizei
eingreift dass die Blockaden so schnell
wie möglich beendet werden und dass die
die Sie zu verantworten haben dann auch
zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden aber
mehr kann der Staat auch nicht tun also
präventiv erschießen dürfte auch keine
Lösung sein und wenn es läuft wenn es
Leute gibt wenn es Leute gibt die sich
festlich nehmen wir die Temperatur auf
aber davon hätte wirklich keine
rehabilen Polizei Einsatz von 500 äh
Beamten in der Hauptstadt an ganz vielen
Stellen ganz viele Kollegen wie willst
du von der Stadtwagen heute zu spät
heute tatsächlich massiv zu spät
gekommen zur einsetzen massiv behindert
worden auf der auf der Hauptstadt
Autobahn und das immer und immer wieder
wird präventiv genug getan also es war
sogar mindest Strafen mittlerweile
sollte man präventiv tun Mindeststrafen
solltest mindest Strafen geben
ehrlich gesagt ich glaube nicht dass es
die Leute um das geht abhält weil das
sind ja diejenigen die im Gefängnis
waren sofort wieder bei der nächsten
klebeaktion dabei gewesen wenn man sich
in Menschen reinversetzt die objektiv
sagen hier herrscht jetzt Notstand weil
wir die Grundlagen dieser Gesellschaft
zerstören da wird nichts gemacht und ich
in meiner letzten Generation daher kommt
ja der Begriff ich muss jetzt was
dagegen tun dann werden sie mit strafan
Drohung vermutlich nicht Fehler
erreichen aber das würde bedeuten man
muss sie gar nicht bestrafen nein der
wenn man der Argumentation vorher
überhaupt das eine 7 monatshaft Strafe
so wie sie sie jetzt einmal zumindest
verhängt wurde durchaus eine in Zukunft
abschreckende Wirkung haben könnte
vielleicht ich glaube halt nicht das ist
diejenigen die sich so da drin versteift
haben wirklich davon abhält und dass die
bereit sind diese Bestrafung hinzunehmen
deswegen ist meine These dass man da
präventiv so viel nicht machen kann
solange es Leute gibt die diese
Weltsicht verinnerlichen wird auch Leute
geben die sich hinkleben und kann nur
gucken dass man dann möglichst schnell
entsprechend entschieden reagiert mehr
wird nicht drin sein am Wochenende gab
es ein großes
renn-event hier Motorsport ja kennt habe
Leute getroffen die damit fahren auf der
Straße ja und möglicherweise kennen Sie
auch den ein oder anderen der sich in
den Weg gestellt hat und dort
festgeklebt hat nein bestimmt nicht wir
haben das Event blockiert und ganz viel
auf der Tribüne und auch die die das in
den Videos gesehen haben die haben sie
gefragt haben die das nicht verstanden
das ist da gar keinen Verbrenner gab
warum setzen die sich jetzt vor ihr
Autos hin haben sie es verstanden
nein habe ich auch nicht verstanden aber
vermutlich ist die Theorie dahinter das
schnelle Autos immer schlecht sind egal
welchen Antrieb sie haben das so mache
ich mir den Reim drauf ist das ihre
Meinung auch nein das ist nicht meine
Meinung also steckt eine Ideologie
dahinter mit der man ja schwer mit Sache
Argumenten noch kommen kann das ist ja
fast bei jeder existenziellen Ideologie
so also das sind die jetzt wirklich
nicht die ersten wenn man sich einen
hermetisch abgeschottet
aufgebaut hat ist übrigens in Teilen ja
durchaus zutreffende Analyse der Lage
ist nämlich die co2-mission weltweit
steigen immer dramatischer die Schäden
für die Menschheit werden immer
schlimmer für die Natur auch und wenn
wir jetzt nicht endlich Umsteuern dann
haben unsere Enkel echt ein Problem mit
der Welt in die sie dann geboren werden
das stimmt einfach alles und jetzt ist
die Frage was soll ich denn tun und die
Leute sagen es wird es passiert einfach
nichts jetzt muss ich zu radikal daran
Methoden greifen und mich festkleben den
Schluss halt ich Verfall falsch weil ich
glaube es gibt schon viel zu viel weiß
nicht voran geht da oder geht ja noch
weniger voran aber ich verstehe erstmal
dass man in so eine Weltsicht hinein
geraten können Sicht sie sprechen mit
diesem Menschen darüber haben wir gerade
schon gesprochen sie sprechen mit den
Klima Klebern haben wir übrigens hier im
Studio auch schon getan sie wollten
jetzt diskutieren auch mit Luisa
Neubauer dazu ist aber nicht gekommen
sie hat das abgesagt sie wollte nicht
mit Ihnen diskutieren
also mir ist berichtet worden ich weiß
es nicht von ihr persönlich das ist eine
Anfrage der Touch gegeben haben soll
eine Diskussion zwischen uns beiden zu
ermöglichen und dass sie die abgesagt
hat was ihr gutes Recht ist sie muss ja
nicht mit mir diskutieren sie sich
gefreut ja sicher was wir Ihnen wichtig
gewesen ihr zu sagen
ich glaube dass wir gut daran tun alle
die das ernst meinen mit dem Klimaschutz
zusammenzuarbeiten und das ist der Sache
gar nicht dient wenn es da Leute gibt
die man als nicht mehr seit es
fraktionsfähig einstuft wegen ganz
anderer fragen weil mir wird eigentlich
von niemand abgesprochen dass deswegen
eine sehr erfolgreiche
Klimaschutzpolitik macht und dann finde
ich das ist wenn es um Klimaschutz geht
auf jeden Fall wäre dass man da dann
zusammen an einem Strang zieht ich habe
das schon öfter erlebt ich bin auch von
Fridays for future Organisationen erst
eingeladen und dann wieder ausgeladen
worden das heißt die diskutieren dann
darüber sollen wir den Palma einladen
dann sagen manche naja Tübingen macht
tolle Klimaschutz Sachen die schauen wir
uns an und dann gucken aber anderen
sagen aber der Palma ist ein Rassist den
kann man doch nicht noch eine Bühne
bieten und dann wird man wieder aus
geladen
das heißt was vermuten sie am Ende für
ein Motiv sind sie sie haben jetzt
Meeres vermischt sind sie sozusagen
gefährlich für die Bewegung weil sie
selber in Tübingen in Teilen erfolgreich
sind oder sind sie nicht
satisfaktionsfähig wie Sie es gerade
gemacht
es geht es gibt eine sehr große
Schnittmenge zwischen denen die moderne
sage ich jetzt mal Identitätspolitik
betreiben wo dann der Maßstab nicht
Leistung Eignung und Befähigung ist um
den Amt zu vergeben sondern Hautfarbe
sexuelle Orientierung Angehörigkeit zu
Minderheiten ich halte es für falsch und
weil ich an der Stelle eine ideologische
Differenz habe wird dann die
Zusammenarbeit in dem Bereich wo die
Übereinstimmung nahe 100% ist auch
aufgekündigt die sind politisch nicht
korrekt genug für Luisa Neubauer und Co
das weiß ich nicht weil sie es mir nicht
persönlich gesagt hat sie ich finde
Vermutungen solche Art sie haben gerade
nein ich habe überleser Neubauer nicht
gesprochen über meine Erfahrung mit
dieser Jugendlichen klimaschutzbewegung
die auch oft identitätspolitisch sehr
klare Auffassungen verdreht im einen
Punkt sind sie mit mir einig und dem
anderen halten sie mich halt wenn ich
seit es fraktionsfähig und ich würde das
sagen Leute dann lasst uns trotzdem über
Klimaschutz reden weil man muss nicht
über alles im Leben immer einig sein
bevor man was gemeinsam machen kann
Schnitt hier drunter wir sprechen über
ganz profanes über das Geld Deutschland
spricht im Moment über eine massive
Tariferhöhung endlich sagen ganz viele
die den Müll Fahren in der Stadt die in
städtischen Kitas Arbeiten die in der
Pflege dort arbeiten und und und und
gibt erstmal 3000 € nette in netto
inflationsprämie also steuerfrei und
dann ab 2024 habe dem ersten März 5,5 %
mehr ist immer schwer zu sagen was ist
gerecht aber trotzdem die Frage ist das
gerecht ist das richtig ist das Pferd
ich halte es für einen guten Kompromiss
für die Kommunen wird sehr sehr teuer
und gerade die Kommunen die finanziell
schlechter stehen werden da echt hat
daran zu knapsen haben für Tübingen ist
es ganz gut leistbar aber ein Gesichts
der Inflation und unserer
Schwierigkeiten überhaupt noch Leute zu
finden die die Jobs machen bin ich jetzt
als Arbeitgeber auch nicht unfroh und
das habe ich heute morgen bewusst auf
Facebook mal geschrieben wenn ich sagen
kann Leute die Jobs bei der Tübingen die
sind echt gut bezahlt überlegt euch mal
ob er da nicht anfangen wollt wir
brauchen euch gibt's also nicht Personen
sondern einzelnen Berufen richtig ganz
besonders gönnen
nein weil das finde ich jetzt wiederum
ist unzulässig wenn man dann sagt ich
könnte jetzt den einen hier angucken mit
der Chef von allen und den anderen nicht
wir würden die mich dann als ihren
Chefin Zukunft angucken das kann man ja
wirklich nicht bringen
werden Sie also das haben sie im Grunde
schon beantworten Gebühren dafür erhöhen
müssen ein sie zahlen das aus den
Rücklagen von Tübingen erwarten Sie das
wie ihre Nachbarstädte für andere Städte
in Baden-Württemberg in Deutschland sie
haben gerade schon die Klammer
Finanzsituation vieler Kommunen
angesprochen werden da also auch wegen
dieser Tariferhöhung jetzt anschließend
die Gebühren vor Ort erhöht werden
Gebühren oder Steuern das kann durchaus
in einzelnen Städten notwendig sein wenn
die Verschuldung über bordet und jetzt
ja auch die Zinsen ansteigen dann bleibt
einem manchmal vielleicht nichts anderes
übrig für Tübingen erwarte ich nicht
aber kann ja schon vorstellen dass das
manche Kommunen in finanzieller Notlage
dann dahin treibt sie machen im Moment
sehr genau die Rechnung auf haben das
gerade auch schon ganz kurz angesprochen
wofür geben wir eigentlich unser Geld in
Deutschland aus geben wir das für die
richtigen Dinge aus und sie sagen
aktuell wenn wir die gesamten Ressourcen
für die neu angekommen sprich für
Flüchtlinge einsetzen aber für die
Menschen vor Ort nichts mehr da ist dann
springt das die Gesellschaft sagen sie
kostet uns unsere Flüchtlingspolitik
also definitiv Wohlstand derzeit ja das
kann man glaube ich nicht bestreiten
einfach weil der Anteil derjenigen die
nicht am Arbeitsmarkt tätig werden immer
noch ziemlich groß ist und dann ist ja
logisch dass es erstmal
Wohlstandsverluste bedeutet der Satz
bezieht sich übrigens insbesondere auf
den Wohnungsmarkt also mir geht es vor
allem darum dass der Wohnungsbau der
öffentliche Wohnungsbau der noch
stattfindet im Prinzip vollständig
benötigt wird um Flüchtlinge
unterzubringen und dann bleibt für den
Ressourcen die wir einsetzen können für
die die vorher schon da waren nichts
mehr übrig und das muss zu sozialen
Fraktionen führen wenn Leute aus der
Stadt wegziehen müssen die ihr ganzes
Leben lang eingezahlt haben mit die
Sozialsysteme und andere die gerade
hergekommen sind und dann denkt dass die
Gesellschaft ja dann die Wohnungen
beziehen können das kann gar nicht
anders sein als dass das die
Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft sprengt
was heißt das was bedeutet das übersetzt
dann springt dass die Gesellschaft
das kann heißen dass es zu protestwahlen
im Osten kommt wo dann afd-landrätige
gewählt werden das kann heißen dass
Leute sagen dann mache ich auch nichts
mehr okay die innere Kündigung oder
lasst den Job gleich ganz bleiben wenn
es Bürgergeld auch nicht wesentlich
weniger Netto bedeutet das in Tübingen
da kennen sie die Menschen am besten
wenn irgendwas die Gesellschaft sprengt
was bedeutet das bei ihnen naja zum
Glück ist Tübingen ist ja wohl situierte
hochgebildete Stadt wir werden
wahrscheinlich die letzten sein bei den
Städten bei denen sowas passiert ist
passiert eher in den abgehängten
Bezirken zuerst der da entstehen dann
die wirklich gravierenden Probleme ich
will jetzt auch nicht darüber
spekulieren was genau dann passiert ich
meine nur dass sie einfach einen Satz
der auch im Kopf bleibt der eine Warnung
ist ein Alarm im Grunde ist dann springt
das die Gesellschaft also es ist auch
gemeint ja das ist jetzt nicht als
Dynamit gemeint im wörtlichen Szene
sondern wenn die Gesellschaft die
Zusammenhalt verliert weil die Leute
sagen akzeptiert einfach gar nicht mehr
was da passiert dann hat man nachher
Probleme überhaupt noch gemeinsam zu
handeln und davor war nicht über diesen
Satz sprechen wir gleich weiter dann
springt dass die Gesellschaft nämlich
die gesamten Ressourcen für die neu
angekommenen einsetzen und dann für die
Menschen vor Ort nichts mehr da ist das
sagt Boris Palma das vertiefen wir
gleich hier bei Bild nach einer ganz
kurzen Pause
zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen an
Boris Palmer der sich ja mit der
Flüchtlingspolitik schwer trägt in
diesen Tagen unter anderem und die
ressourcenfrage aufgemacht hat er sagt
wenn wir all unsere Ressourcen einsetzen
für die neu angekommenen und dann für
die Menschen vor Ort eben nichts mehr da
ist dann springt das die Gesellschaft
heißt übersetzt doch sie würden aktuell
natürlich aus ihrer Sicht lieber
Tübingen an die Wohnung das Geld geben
als Syrer
sind ja wenn sie vom Krieg betroffen
sind bleibeberechtigt und wenn
Asylantrag mal positiv beschieden ist
dann gibt's auch da nichts mehr
rumzudeuten aber sehr neu angekommen sie
sagen ja neu angekommen also wenn zu
ihnen im Moment kommen Ukraine neu
angekommen Afghan neue angekommen Syrer
neu angekommen und so weiter und Sie
haben die Wahl das ist ja das Thema was
sie aufmachen die Ressourcen jetzt
einzusetzen sagen sie na dann lieber
jemand der schon hier war also lieber
ja ich möchte aber eine andere Gruppe
ins Bild nehmen nämlich die Gruppe derer
die kein Bleiberecht haben und die geht
mir also dass man sich
für die einsetzen muss den bleibe
Anspruch haben das ist halt einfach
Tatsache daran kann man nicht rumdeuten
und ich glaube wir beide würden auch
nicht sagen die Ukrainer sollen mal
heimgehen und das soll keiner bei uns
wohnen dürfen das sagt doch gar keiner
ja von daher versuche den Satz genau zu
verstehen genau deswegen will ich ihn
erklären ich habe dabei nicht die
Gruppen die sie jetzt gerade
angesprochen haben im Blick sondern die
Hälfte aller der Asyl beantragen in
Deutschland erhalten gar keins bekommen
kein Bleiberecht und die sind halt
gerade nicht aus Syrien oder der Ukraine
und das sind die Zahlen stark
angestiegen wir haben jetzt 80.000
Erstanträge in den ersten drei Monaten
dieses Jahres das heißt aufs Jahr
gerechnet geht Richtung 400.000 im
Sommer ist in der Regel mehr und 400.000
ist fast so viel wie 2015 und da muss
man einfach mal sagen das ist zu viel
das führt zu den von mir beschriebenen
ressourcenkonflikten ich möchte die
irreguläre Migration drastisch drücken
ich finde dass diejenigen die gar keinen
Grund haben jedenfalls richtig gesehen
außer Armut das ist sicher der Fall zu
uns zu kommen dass die dann auch nicht
in den Kommunen wohn erhalten soll
können Sie nur ja fast gar nicht machen
ihnen werden immer mehr Flüchtlinge
zugewiesen wir hören heute aus Hannover
das erstmal so was wie ein Aufnahme
stoppt dort in der ersten deutschen
Großstadt verhängt wird ein bisschen
hart formuliert aber die Stadt hat jetzt
heute Ende April ihr Jahres soll erfüllt
ja das Jahres soll für dieses Jahr
2023 ähnlich wird es bei Ihnen
möglicherweise in Tübingen aussehen also
welche handhaber haben sie als
Bürgermeister können Sie jetzt sagen
okay Freunde also
ich habe keine Hand habe deswegen können
wir in den Städten und Gemeinden nur
immer wieder Appelle formulieren und
mittlerweile haben meines Wissens alle
Städte und Gemeinde Bünde die Landkreis
Tage in ganz Deutschland ganz klar
formuliert es sind zu viele wir können
nicht so viele aufnehmen die Zahlen
müssen gedrückt werden und es musste
deswegen etwas gegen die irreguläre
Migration unternommen werden eine
Aufnahme Stopp kommt für sie nicht in
Frage ist für sie nicht möglich
durchzusetzen in Tübingen dass du
irgendwann sagen Freunde ich habe
einfach keine Wohnung mehr ich habe
keinen Platz mehr das ist rechtlich
nicht möglich damit würde ich mich
strafbar machen was würden Sie dann tun
zählt auf fehlenden Straßen das ist das
letzte instrument was man hat Zelte auf
Plätzen ja sind sie schon soweit nein
sind wir nicht wir haben Tübingen bisher
noch eine Situation bei der ich das
nicht erwarte aber es wird zunächst mal
mehr und mehr in die Turnhallen gehen
das ist das was man als erstes belegen
kann und wenn gar nichts mehr da ist im
Zeltstädte dann irgendwann die
Konsequenz aber es geht wir könnten die
reguläre Migration drücken darum müssen
wir eigentlich diskutieren was fehlt
Ihnen ganz konkret an Ressourcen für
diejenigen die schon hier sind so haben
sie es ja formuliert weil immer mehr
kommen also wo fehlt ganz konkret an
Ressourcen also erstmal fällt in der
Finanzierung der Bund sagt ja die
Kommunen brauchen kein Geld das ist
schon mal wirklich eine Unverschämtheit
weil die Kosten dramatisch steigen und
dann vielleicht einmal konkret also was
kostet jetzt ein neu angekommener bei
Ihnen oder eine neu angekommene Familie
was kostet das was kostet ein Kita Platz
den man finanziert was haben sie sonst
verlaufende Kosten in der Kommune da
muss ich jetzt passen ich kann ihnen
nicht die Kosten pro Kopf
machen aber es ist ein fünfstelliger
Betrag den ein aufgenommener jedes Jahr
zwangsläufig braucht Bürgergeld Kita
Kosten Sprachkurse Sozialarbeit die
ganzen behördlichen Auflagen drumherum
Unterstützung sind also da ist man
schnell bei einem fünfstelligen Betrag
aber das Statistische Bundesamt weiß es
besser als ich weiß ich Ihnen sagen kann
ist das Geld ist nicht mal das zentrale
Problem ist halt einfach nicht in
Ordnung dass man die Kommunen damit der
Aufgabe allein lässt und die dann gucken
sollen wo das Geld herkommt darüber
ärger ich mich viel wichtiger ist dass
man das was man mit dem Geld bezahlen
will oft gar nicht mehr kaufen kann also
ich kann kein Kita Personal bezahlen
weil es keine Bewerbungen gibt ich kann
keine Wohnungen bauen lassen weil es
dafür keine Bauplätze gibt und auch
keine Unternehmen die sich so schnell
herstellen können und wenn ich sie bauen
lassen das ist so absurd teuer
mittlerweile dass der Preise von 20 €
den Quadratmeter rauskommen und man sich
dann echt fragt
wie sollte es eigentlich noch
funktionieren ja wer soll das dann am
Ende wirklich bezahlen es gibt die Ärzte
nicht mehr die ganze medizinische
Versorgung ung leisten können auf dem
Land jeder Flüchtling der dazu
zusätzlichen Wartezimmer kommt
verschlechtert halt die medizinische
Qualität der Versorgung und so können
Sie das durchgehen die ganzen
Hilfssysteme sind so voll ausgelastet
durch die über eine Million Ukraine und
die über 1,5 Millionen die den Jahren
vorher schon gekommen sind und viele
noch in den hilfsystem drin stecken das
alles was jetzt oben drauf kommt dazu
führt dass ein System nach dem anderen
gibt nicht mehr Beiträge wegen der
flüchtlingskrise wegen des Zugs
das wird überwiegend ja aus
Steuermitteln finanziert das heißt eher
würden dann die Steuer steigen aber ich
glaube da ist Lindner davor also wird es
am Ende die Staatsschuld sein die das
begleitet aber auch dieses System kommt
wegen der Flüchtlingspolitik an die
Grenzen des Gesundheitssystem personell
auf jeden Fall die geflüchteten haben
oft noch einen hohen Zusatzaufwand weil
die Verständigungsprobleme da sind krank
werden sie zwangsläufig auch und dann
schlagen sie immer häufig in der
Notaufnahme der Kliniken auf weil sie
sonst irgendwie im System nicht
untergebracht werden müssen die nicht
mehr wie sie klarkommen sollen das sind
einfach begrenzt belastbare Systeme die
man nicht ohne weiteres schnell ausbauen
kann wenn man dafür hochqualifiziertes
Personal braucht das ist nicht gibt und
deswegen heißt immer noch mehr Leute
dass die Qualität sind das ist glaube
ich eine ganz simple Rechnung sie nennen
das eine absurde Form der
Selbstbestätigung aus Prinzip so haben
sie es kürzlich in einem Vortrag in
einer Rede bei sich in Tübingen
formuliert eine absurde Form der
Selbstbestätigung aus Prinzip
Deutschland schadet sich also selbst aus
Prinzip das klingt ein bisschen wie
Deutschland schafft sich ab
an die Analogie habe ich nicht gedacht
aber wichtig ist glaube ich der Bezug
des Satzes dieses selbstschädigen aus
Prinzip habe ich auf abschieben von
Arbeitskräften bezogen in meiner Stadt
habe ich wirklich in den letzten Monaten
dauernd Kontakt mit Unternehmen die
sagen mein Metallarbeiter mein
fahrradmonteur mein Logistiker die
sollen abgeschoben werden und dann
werden die abgeschoben das ist auch ganz
vieles bezogen ja stimmt aber sie haben
zuvor natürlich genau darüber gesprochen
über den Punkt bei dem wir gerade waren
sie haben in ihre Rede darüber
gesprochen wer zu uns kommt haben dann
analysiert dass darunter sehr sehr wenig
Fachkräfte sind und dass wir dann eben
letztendlich die falschen ist doch
absurd oder also die Kriminellen dürfen
hier bleiben wenn man sie nicht zu
fassen kriegt die bundesinnenministerin
sagten Vergewaltiger aus Afghanistan der
bei den Taliban war der soll hier
bleiben weil das ist so gefährlich für
den Afghanistan ehrlich gesagt das ist
mir egal was ist mit den 33 Millionen
Aufgaben für die Afghanistan immer schon
gefährlich war wenn der vergewaltigt
dann muss ergeben das verhindert die
bundesinnenministerin und gleichzeitig
kriege ich dauernd die Meldungen von
Abschiebungen von gut integrierten
Fachkräften das ist doch wirklich selbst
Schädigung aus Prinzip warum die Frage
nach dem Warum ist nicht beantwortet
haben sie dafür eine Erklärung
wenn ich die hätte würde ich ja
vielleicht von heute auf morgen lösen
wie man das Problem nicht sehen will man
sich da einfach nicht auseinandersetzen
mit Wimmern weiterhin guten Ruf genießen
will man drüber weg regieren über diese
Probleme warum warum eine absurde
Selbstschädigung wie sie das nennen also
ich bin ja Anhänger des Charity
principles das heißt versuche immer das
Bestmögliche Argument für die Position
deines Gegners zu benutzen und die nicht
von vorne rein zum Deppen zu erklären ja
weil das finde da meistens auch nicht
sonderlich nett und wenn ich das mache
und sage okay was sind denn die
bestmöglichen Positionen zur
Verteidigung des Status quo dann sage
ich gut ist dass man helfen will
Menschen die in Not sind gut ist dass
man Leute nicht einfach in den Tod
schicken möchte sondern Menschlichkeit
auch zeigen will wenn es schwierig wird
und gut ist auch dass man
wenn jemand kein Recht hat in
Deutschland zu sein sagt so hier ist das
Flugzeug jetzt geht es wieder nach Hause
das Absurde ist nur dass das jeweilige
Prinzip meiner Meinung nach gerade an
den falschen Stellen sich durchsetzt
also die Abschiebung kommt nicht bei den
Kriminellen durch sondern bei den guten
Arbeitskräften und die Hilfe wird dann
auf denen zu teilen die sie eigentlich
gar nicht benötigt hätten also das
operative Handling ist so schlecht das
Ergebnis herauskommt wo ich sage 70 oder
80% der Leute wollen das gar nicht so
die würden das gerne umgekehrt haben
also jetzt haben sie ein Stück weit über
Unvermögen erklärt und über den guten
wählen doch möglichst vielen
Menschlichkeit zu zeigen und sie werden
die Momente aber vermutlich auch haben
wo sie sagen am Ende doch ein bisschen
Deppen oder es gibt Momente wo ich mich
frage ob die andere Seite des ernst
meint was sie da sagt aber das mit dem
Leben sollte man sich behalten haben sie
in dem Moment im Kopf
insbesondere die Leute die den modernen
identitätstheorien nachhängen und zum
Beispiel von strukturellem Rassismus
reden und alten weißen Männern und dabei
eigentlich doch merken müssten dass sie
die Kategorien des Rassismus zum Maßstab
der Entscheidungen machen nur plötzlich
mit umgekehrten Vorzeichen ich glaube
halt nicht dass dadurch irgendwas besser
wird ich bin wirklich ein Anhänger der
gesellschaftergleichen alle sind
Menschen und würde jetzt ungern damit
anfangen alle Positionen streng nach
sexuellen Vorlieben zu besetzen weil ich
glaube das ist einfach nichts besser
machen da denke ich mir merken die nicht
was sie sagen aber es einmal zurück
konkret bei ihnen in Tübingen wie groß
ist der Anteil wie groß die Anzahl derer
bei denen sie jetzt sagen würden die
sind aus den vergangenen Jahren gekommen
und die sind richtig gut integriert bei
denen hat geklappt also die neueren
Statistiken die ich gesehen habe sagen
wir dass wir das Sonnen Wert von
ungefähr 50% erreicht haben 50% 50%
werden sie sensationell unterwegs
wir sind glaube ich gut unterwegs wir
haben von Anfang an darauf geachtet dass
wir dezentrale Unterbringung bauen dass
wir für alle geflüchtete Ansprechpartner
haben dass wir die
Arbeitsmarktintegration zum Maßstab
machen Tübingen ich glaube ich die
einzige Stadt die in Stipendium für
Auszubildende geflüchtete hat wo man die
ersten sechs Monate von der Stadt
bezahlt bekommen damit Betriebe
austesten können ob die jungen Leute was
kennen und so ungefähr 50% glaube ich
nach sechs Jahren können wir als Erfolg
wirklich jetzt logischerweise viel
schlechter aus vor allen Dingen in den
Großstädten für wie groß halten sie für
wie hoch die Quote bundesweit natürlich
schwer weil ich da keinen konkreten
Zugang dazu habe ich würde lieber über
Sachen reden die ich wirklich verstehe
und die bundesdaten da müsste ich mich
sehr Einarbeiten in die Statistiken wir
haben kürzlich gehört von einer ersten
Schulklasse Schulklasse 1 in
Ludwigshafen wo jetzt 40 Schüler in
einer Schule sitzen bleiben weil sie
schlichtweg kein Deutsch sprechen was
würden Sie als Lehrer
einer solchen Klasse machen
keine Ahnung ich glaube dass kaum ein
Lehrer so eine Aufgabe übernehmen möchte
und da wir nicht genügend Lehrer haben
um alle Klassen zu bestücken heißt es da
wird man irgendwann vor der Situation
stehen dass einfach niemand mehr da ist
der den Job machen will und dass die
Bildungsleistungen dadurch immer
schlechter werden ist auch nicht zu
bestreiten das Bildung kann man auf dem
Niveau wenn die Sprache nicht versteht
ja eigentlich gar nicht sprechend das
ist wohl wahr aber das ist ja so ein
Effekt der sich dann durch das
Bildungssystem insgesamt durchzieht wo
einzelne versuchen sich rauszuziehen in
diesem Privatschulen ihre Kinder
hinschicken gerne auch grüne Eltern weil
Bildung ist uns wichtig aber insgesamt
ist Leistungsniveau absinkt weil wir
nicht in der Lage sind genügend
Lehrkräfte bereitzustellen die die
erhöhten Anforderungen von Klassen wo
viele Kinder kein Deutsch sprechen
konnte
das gibt's auch im inklusionsbereich ich
glaube nicht dass man eins zu eins
Betreuung braucht jetzt bei geflüchteten
Kindern die ansonsten gesund sind aber
jedenfalls haben wir die Ressourcen
nicht und es ist wieder das Thema was
ich vorher sagte ja wenn es dann für
alle schlecht da wird wenn man nicht
mehr in der Lage ist die Menschen zu
finden die die Arbeiten machen dann hat
man ein Problem und es wäre schon mal
ganz gut wenn man das Problem nüchtern
aussprechen dürfte ohne gleich als
Rassist oder Flüchtling die Familie zu
werden ihre Kinder in eine solche Klasse
schicken ja das wäre gelogen nein ich
will mein Kind nicht in die Klasse
schicken wo kein Kind dort spricht
also wenn möglich Privatschule raus aus
dem System in Tübingen sind auch die
öffentlichen Schulen sehr gut ich habe
die Entscheidung zum Glück nicht zu
treffen es gibt folgen diesem Gespräch
leider noch eine Welt außerhalb von
Tübingen und es gibt schulzuweisungen
die Frage stellt sich für
Jahrhunderttausende Eltern ganz konkret
diese Schule die einem zugewiesen wird
oder dann sich dem Schulsystem entziehen
meine Kinder sind das wichtigste für
mich und wenn deren Bildungen Gefahr ist
treffe ich die Entscheidung für die
bestmögliche Bildung die sie kriegen
können und dann würde ich in so einer
Situation wo sie beschreiben würde ich
mich auch für eine private Schule
entscheiden zurück bleiben dann diese
Kinder die kein Wort Deutsch sprechen
oder nur bruchstückhaft die aus dem
Elternhaus möglicherweise kaum Bildung
bisher mitbekommen haben die Eltern
möglicherweise keinen Schulabschluss
Migrationshintergrund ein kleiner
Geldbeutel die Statistiken sagen aus
diesen Kindern wird sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich niemand mit einem höheren
Einkommen niemand der in unserem
Bildungserfolg Erfolg haben im in
unserem Bildungssystem Erfolg haben wird
ja wird das eine Klasse immer von
Sozialhilfeempfängern sein dieses
vererben von Sozialhilfe Status ist
nichts neues das hat Deutschland über
Jahrzehnte genauso erfahren wir sind
nicht aufmerk mobil genug anders als z.B
klassische anwendungsländer wie die
Vereinigten Staaten und es liegt daran
dass wir nicht genügend Wert auf Arbeits
Supermarkt Integration und auf Leistung
setzen meiner Meinung nach ist das die
Krux wir verlangen zu wenig wir fordern
zu wenig und dann schrecken wir auch
noch ab indem wir irrsinnige
bürokratische Anforderungen stellen also
nicht an die Person sondern an die
formale Qualifikation so dass Leute die
selbst eine Arztausbildung haben bei uns
nicht arbeiten können und dann besser
von Bürgergeld das ist sehr brutal sie
könnten in die Schulklasse in die erste
Klasse nach Ludwigshafen gehen können
dort rein spazieren als Boris Palma
können den Kindern die nichts dafür
können ins Gesicht gucken und sagen so
das ist eine sozialhilfe-karriere
zumindest mit sehr sehr hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit und gleichzeitig
können Sie sich in den Spiegel gucken
und sagen okay und für die 40 werden wir
unser Leben lang zahlen
oder es gelingt uns für diese Gruppen
die keine deutschsprachigen Elternhäuser
haben ganz gezielte Angebote zu machen
dafür gibt es vorbereitungsklassen dass
man die heranführt und sie dann so gut
mit Sprachkompetenz ausstattet das sieht
dann doch noch Teil der Gesellschaft
werden können und dafür braucht halt
Leute in der Theorie das ist schon auch
in der Praxis möglich aber es wird dafür
zu wurde dafür zu wenig gemacht und
jetzt haben wir ein Problem der
Überlastung weil es einfach auch die
Leute nicht mehr gibt dies tun können
die Jahrgänge der Berufsanfänger sind so
klein dass uns die Person die es machen
können einfach nicht zur Verfügung
stehen wir sprechen darüber wie sich
Deutschland verändert hat sie haben
schon an einigen Punkten vor allen
Dingen mit Blick auf die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung auch in Baden-Württemberg
bisschen düsterer Aussichten gezeichnet
wir haben jetzt gesprochen wie sich
unser Bildungssystem verändert hat wie
sich der Kampf um Ressourcen auch
verändert hat wenn sie durch Deutschland
laufen auch durch Berlin beispielsweise
heute gelaufen sind wo sehen Sie sofort
wie sich Deutschland in der vergangenen
Jahren verändert hat
das sehe ich zum Glück nicht also ich
finde nicht dass das direkt sichtbar ist
es eigentlich eher umgekehrt wir alle
haben irgendwie so eine Art Wohlstands
Illusion weil es ist irgendwie so
kölsches Motto es ist nur immer
jutijacke es geht ja Deutschland nicht
schlecht also auch meiner Stadt geht es
nicht schlecht im Gegenteil wenn ich die
Parameter anguckt Steuereinnahmen höher
als je zuvor und man kann so irgendwie
Illusion verfallen es wird schon immer
weitergehen ist aber nicht so sondern
eigentlich ist es so dass diese vielen
viele Probleme die wir jetzt sagen immer
analysieren dass sie sich auftürmen
immer größer werden und das daran noch
zu wenig gedacht oder wenn man es nicht
spürt es gibt keinen Schmerz sagt ganz
viele spüren das natürlich längste das
ist ein bisschen die wohlstandsinsel die
viele bei uns eben noch genießen die
Wohlstands Illusion die möglicherweise
bei Ihnen noch ein bisschen länger trägt
auch in den Arbeitsplatz die einen
suchen die meisten Arbeitslosigkeit ist
Geschichte das heißt der Schmerz den man
normalerweise hat weniger
Volkswirtschaft in solche Krise
hineinsteuer wie unsere das vermutlich
tut der tritt nicht auch weil so wenig
Leute da sind die Jobs machen könnten
und dann merkt man nicht dass die
Wertschöpfung immer kleiner wird und
irgendwann der Verteilungsspielraum Weg
ist bzw man merkt sie erst dann wenn es
zu spät ist das ist glaube ich das
Problem also Deutschland hat sich ihrem
Eindruck nach ihrem oberflächeneindruckt
wenn Sie einfach die Stadt laufen laufen
nicht verändert wenig verändert also
nicht so dramatisch dass ich jetzt sagen
würde dass irgendwas schlechter als vor
fünf Jahren viele machen das am Thema
Gewalt
tatsächlich fest und sagen gar nicht
dass sich die Gewalt verdoppelt
verdreifacht hat das zeigen die
Statistiken ja auch nicht aber dass ich
bestimmte Teile von der Gewalt vor allen
Dingen mit Messern Bahn gebrochen haben
hat sich und zweifelhaft das sehe ich
aber nicht also ich war noch nie dabei
sie sehen aber die Taten sie sehen die
Videos dieser sie sehen die Statistiken
macht ihnen das Angst Angst macht mir
noch nicht weil ich versuche Risiken in
Größenordnungen einzuschätzen und ich
weiß dass es ein sehr seltenes Ereignis
ist nach wie vor also Autos sind einfach
gefährlicher als Messerträger da
passieren viel natürliche unfällig aber
trotzdem Auto habe ich auch keine Angst
vor es geht einfach was anderes es geht
um die psychische Wirkung der
Verunsicherung und die kommt eben daher
dass diese Ereignisse extrem öffentlich
sind und dass sie im Prinzip wie aus
halt am Himmel kommen ja wenn das so
Messer oder Leute in Regionalzügen
wahllos Menschen abstichen oder halt im
Stadtpark oder
Mädchen auf dem Schulweg dann erregt es
zu Recht eine riesige Aufmerksamkeit und
macht Ängste die auch insoweit begründet
sind als man einfach sagen muss da muss
es doch möglich sein vorherseits des
Staates dafür zu sorgen dass es nicht
passiert wieder Vergewaltigung hat
massiv zugenommen zumindest in
Nordrhein-Westfalen da gibt es gerade
aktuelle Zahlen darunter wahnsinnig
erschreckend viele nämlich mehrere
hundert Gruppen Vergewaltigung ein
Phänomen das mir ehrlich gesagt relativ
fremd war bis vor einigen Jahren und das
jetzt immer häufiger eben in
Polizeimeldungen in Statistiken
auftaucht da wäre es einfach wichtig
sich einzugestehen dass es statistische
Zusammenhänge geben kann die auch
Herkunft betreffen wäre ja sehr
merkwürdig wenn das die einzige
Korrelation ist die nicht existiert die
von vornherein gar nicht sein können und
wenn man sich das eingesteht dass das
möglich sein könnte dann die Zahlen
nicht dann alles wird dann stellt man
fest bei schweren Straftaten wie wir sie
gerade diskutieren sind die Asylbewerber
etwa fünffach überrepräsentiert also
gemessen an der Zahl der Menschen die da
sind gibt es fünf Mal mehr solche
schweren strafze
also ich habe zum Beispiel mitbekommen
dass die bundesinnenministerin die
Tatsache dass der Anteil der
Tatverdächtigen Asylbewerber sich um 30
Prozent erhöht hat das nicht mal auf der
Jahrespressekonferenz thematisieren
wollte sondern das eine Polizisten
überlassen hat und wenn man als
bundesinnenministerin zu sowas gar nicht
mehr Stellung nimmt dann ist es schon
besorgniserregend besteht sicher ihre
grüne Partei
meine grüne Partei hat damit größte
Schwierigkeiten weil sie sofort die
Rassismus Schablone drüberlegt also es
gelingt kaum das nüchtern anzusprechen
weil es dann unmittelbar als
rassistische Kategorie abgegrenzelt wird
und ich finde das Statistik und Logik
erstmal nicht rassistisch sein können
allenfalls wenn man was draus macht wenn
ich jetzt sagen würde alle schwarzen
sind Verbrecher ist das Rassismus wenn
ich sage statistisch gesehen sind Gambia
10% 10% aller Gambia in
Baden-Württemberg wegen Drogendelikten
schon bei der Polizei bekannt dann ist
es erstmal eine Tatsache die auch wenn
Sie einer Kategorie Herkunft festmachen
nicht rassistisch sein kann sondern
Statistik ist wir haben in den letzten
Minuten darüber gesprochen wie sich
Deutschland verändert hat in den
vergangenen Jahren ist Deutschland mit
dieser Regierung mit dieser
ampelregierung unter grüner Beteiligung
grüner geworden der unbedingt also es
gibt auch Sachen die echt toll laufen
jetzt haben wir uns ja schöne Depression
rein geredet ich habe so lange dafür
gekämpft dass man endlich Windräder und
Solaranlagen in Deutschland bauen darf
und ich habe so geguckt wie die
Bundesregierung und vor allem unterhauen
darf schon bauen darf nein ja aber man
baut ja kaum welche doch es wird
wesentlich mehr und bei ihnen sind die
bei weitem nicht aus belasteten
Baden-Württemberg und in Bayern nein
aber ich sehe jetzt dass die
Baugenehmigung laufen für die ich mir
vorher blutige Nasen geholt habe wir
werden rund um Tübingen jetzt Windräder
bauen wir kriegen die Genehmigung und
das verdanken wir Robert habe gefragt
ist Deutschland grüner geworden sie
sagen jetzt weil man jetzt
Baugenehmigung bekommt theoretisch ist
Deutschland grüner geworden ich sage
praktisch dauert es zwei drei Jahre ein
bisschen Windrad steht das kann ich
anders sein aber wenn ich in drei Jahren
wieder mit Ihnen spreche werden sie rund
um Tübingen Windräder stehen haben und
von einem Jahr hätte ich ihm gesagt es
wird gar keine geben weil die
Genehmigung dafür nicht zu bekommen sind
und habe jetzt tatsächlich geschafft das
ist jetzt möglich ist Genehmigung für
Windräder in Deutschland zu erhalten das
wird das Land verändern also unverhofft
ist das die Sendung die Robert Habeck
heute schauen muss weil so viel von
Boris Palma hat für ihn glaube ich
selten in einer einzigen Stunde gegeben
danke Ihnen für das Gespräch für das
ansonsten aber sehr kritische Gespräch
mit ja viel Kritik an der
Bundesregierung an unserem
gesellschaftlichen Verhalten vor allen
Dingen mit Blick auf die
Flüchtlingspolitik sagte in diesem Land
danke Boris Palma hier bei Bild zurück
nächste Woche bis dahin
[Musik]